[Musique]
oui cette division de la société en
classes n'a jamais été aussi évident
qu'aujourd'hui
oui aujourd'hui tout le monde peut voir
que le fossé qui sépare ceux qui
accumulent des profits et ceux qui
vivent leur seul travail s'est
approfondie il s'élargit de jour en jour
ceux qui gouvernent ce pays depuis 20
ans que la crise ont commencé on veut
volontairement consciemment créé creuser
l'écart entre la petite couche de riches
et la majorité de la population pour
compenser les effets de la crise qui ne
permettait pas à la production de
continuer à augmenter
faute de clients pouvant payer la
bourgeoisie avec l'aide du gouvernement
de tous les gouvernements à peser sur
les salaires afin que les marges du
patronat et des capitalistes en général
ne diminue pas
résultat alors que les profits et les
revenus du capital ont pris 10 ans
avance les salaires eux ont pris dix ans
de retard
[Musique]
et surtout surtout le chômage a augmenté
dans des conditions dramatiques car le
patronat n'a pas eu à essayer de
maintenir sa production pour maintenir
ses profits diminuer les coûts en
licenciant lui a suffi pour la
bourgeoisie c'était et c'est une période
d'argent facile les gouvernements
successifs toutes étiquettes confondues
ont imposé aux travailleurs le blocage
des salaires et comme il n'y a pour
ainsi dire pas de familles de
travailleurs sans un chômeur sans un
jeune qui cherche un emploi
cela pèse encore plus sur le niveau de
vie de tous lorsqu'a commencé cette
longue période de stagnation de
croissance faible voire de reculs qui
caractérisent l'économie depuis quelque
vingt ans ce personnel politique a fait
en sorte que la minorité de riches non
seulement ne souffre pas de la
stagnation économique mais au contraire
en tirent profit
après 1980 les dirigeants socialistes
appuyé pendant trois ans par le parti
communiste ou alors fait pire que de ne
pas organiser la résistance des
travailleurs aux attaques patronales
ils ont utilisé le crédit qu'ils avaient
parmi les travailleurs pour les désarmer
pour les ligoter face aux attaques
ce sont les dirigeants de ces partis
devenu ministre
grâce aux suffrages des ouvriers qui se
sont mis à affirmer plus fort que la
droite noël faire depuis longtemps que
les patrons avait raison de faire le
maximum de profit et qu'il n'y avait pas
moyen de combattre le chômage
autrement qu'en aidant les entreprises
capitalistes à être de plus en plus
riches
ce sont eux qui ont décidé
tous ceux qui ont décidé en 1982 le
premier blocage des salaires non
seulement les ministres de l'union de la
gauche ont pris la responsabilité de
plan de restructuration qui a impliqué
de nombreux licenciements n'hésitent ils
ont affirmé qu'ils le faisaient dans
l'intérêt bien compris des oubliés non
seulement ils ont décidé ce blocage des
salaires mais ils ont dit que c'étaient
les sols politique réaliste ne pas
compromettre l'expérience de l'union de
la gauche
voilà l'argument avec lequel ils ont
compromis d'autant bas les militants
ouvriers qui accordaient leur confiance
au parti socialiste ou au parti
communiste en les amenant à répercuter
auprès des travailleurs
le réalisme de ces messieurs les
ministres de gauche
voilà l'argument qu'il aura servie de
let motiv pour justifier l'injustifiable
voilà comment ils ont mis leurs
militants au service de la guerre
patronale voilà comment ils ont
démoralisé la classe ouvrière comment
ils l'ont laissé sans objectifs
revendicatifs sans programme c'est à
dire sans espoir le parti communiste
d'abord puis le parti socialiste ont
fini par payer eux mêmes cette politique
sur le plan électoral
mais si cher qu ils les paient ce n'est
rien à côté du prix payé par la grande
masse des travailleurs
tu peux nous d'interaction meeting dans
l'etna oui c'était comme j'espérais avec
beaucoup de monde avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé
et on va voter dimanche si on vote pour
elle c'est vrai beaucoup de voix au
premier tour
ce sera un vote pour la lutte un vote
pour le troisième tour social dont il ya
besoin aujourd'hui
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que la
candidature d'arlette quand même donne
donne espoir et on a aujourd'hui des
travailleurs qui certainement donneront
leur voix je le pense je l'espère dans
le cadre de cette campagne au premier
tour pour arlette je dis pas au deuxième
tour mais au troisième tour on les
retrouvera dans la baie hier ça j'en
suis convaincu parce qu'en 93 on avait
donné un exemple vraiment ce qu a dit
arlette mais je suis d'accord enfin pour
faire avec et autour de moi ya plein de
gens qui sont d'accord et qui voteront
pour être cette fois pour la première
fois
oui ce qui se propose de voter pour ma
candidature sont de plus en plus
nombreux mais il y en a aussi certains
qui tout en étant d'accord avec ce que
je dis tu en pensant qu'il faudrait
effectivement appliqué le plan d'urgence
que je propose hésitent à faire ce geste
parce qu'on leur dit par ailleurs qu'il
faut voter utile et cela dès le premier
tour
eh bien oui il faut voter utile mais
votez utile pour un travailleur ses
maîtres le vote qui servira le mieux à
défendre les intérêts de sa classe ce
n'est pas apporté sa voix un politicien
professionnel qui ne se disent
socialistes que pour mieux tromper les
masses populaires et qui mènerait
ensuite s'il était élu la même politique
que ses rivaux de droite comme le parti
socialiste l'a fait de 1981 à 1986 et de
88 à 93
parmi les triplé dont on nous dit qu'ils
ont une chance d'être élus il y a deux
vrais jumeaux chirac et balladur
ils appartiennent au même parti ils ont
gouverné ensemble et ce qui les sépare
ce n'est que leurs ambitions
personnelles respectives
mais pour le troisième jospin il faut
des verres grossissant vraiment puissant
pour voir des différences entre son
programme et celui des deux autres
il se dit de gauche mais à quoi sert une
gauche qui ne sait faire que la
politique de la droite
j'avais dit en 1974
j'ai répété en 1980 1988 que les
travailleurs n'avaient rien de bon à
attendre du faux homme de gauche qu'est
mitterrand les faits ont donné raison
car les différents gouvernements
socialistes qui se sont succédé sous sa
présidence il compris celui auquel
participèrent des ministres communistes
et qui mis en place le blocage des
salaires ont tous mené une politique
consistant à faire supporter le poids de
la crise aux classes laborieuses la même
politique que celle que poursuivi le
gouvernement chirac de 86 à 88 et le
gouvernement balladur de 1993 à
aujourd'hui
noël lionel jospin qui prétend à
l'héritage au moins partielle de
mitterrand voudrait que les travailleurs
lui délivre un chèque en blanc en votant
pour lui dès le premier tour
eh bien non les travailleurs doivent
montrer qu'ils n'acceptent plus ce jeu
de qui gagne perd qu'on leur propose à
chaque élection qui gagne perd parce
qu'à chaque fois que la droite est
écartée du gouvernement
grâce aux voix des classes populaires le
parti socialiste prend le relais pour
continuer en fait la même politique que
cette droite est la seule manière de
montrer qu'on accepte plus cela ces deux
voté pour ma candidature parce que je
suis la seule candidate qui se réclament
de la classe ouvrière et qui n'a aucune
responsabilité directe ou indirecte dans
la politique menée depuis 14 ans parce
que vous savez tous que les voix qui se
porteront sur mon nom je n'en ferais pas
un marchepied pour mener une carrière de
politicien
parce que je représente un courant
politique qui est resté fidèle aux
idéaux du mouvement ouvrier et qui ne
s'est jamais compromis dans le soutien
des gouvernements bourgeois ou des
dictatures staliniennes que deux ou
trois millions de travailleuses et de
travailleurs fassent ce geste n'est pas
utopique
tout le monde sait aujourd'hui que c'est
une possibilité
et je dis à tous ceux qui évite qu'ils
doivent le faire car c'est le vote plus
utile que peuvent émettre aujourd'hui
les travailleurs la politique qu'il
faudrait mener est à l'exact opposé de
celle qui a été poursuivie jusqu'à
présent la première des urgences c'est
le chômage
il faut cesser de verser de l'argent à
fonds perdus ou patronat arrêter toutes
les aides toutes les subventions qui ne
servent qu'à enrichir encore plus ceux
qui sont déjà riches s'en créé un seul
emploi
ces milliards dépensés jusqu'ici en pure
perte doivent être utilisés directement
par l'état
d'abord pour créer des emplois dans les
services publics
certes à tous l'état doit embaucher
immédiatement du personnel dans les
hôpitaux à la poste à la sncf dans
l'enseignement parce que c'est
nécessaire pour avoir des services
publics de qualité
jusqu'ici c'est en effet sur les
services publics qu'on a économisé pour
pouvoir donner au patronat il faut
inverser le mouvement
ils sont reprendre au patronat pour
donner aux services publics
parce que ses services sont utiles à la
population et parce qu'il n'y a aucune
raison que l'argent public ne servent
qu'à produire du profit privé
et puis il faut aussi que l'état
investisse dans les domaines cela est
nécessaire
en créant directement des emplois depuis
des années la construction de logements
populaires stagnent ou reculent
eh bien il faut que l'état prenne
directement en charge la construction de
tels logements
il faudrait construire des écoles
nouvelle est aussi reconstruire des
anciennes dont on sait que ce sont des
dangers publics comme ces dizaines de
crs pailleron qui sont encore utilisés
sans qu'on ne fasse rien jusqu'au
prochain incendies mortels peut-être
l'état pourrait ouvrir de grands travaux
dans bien d'autres domaines encore
développer des infrastructures
collectives créer des parcs des espaces
verts dans les villes ou les banlieues
où la population est en passe et
désenclaver ces banlieues pour les
rendre plus vivable et tout cela il
faudrait le faire sans passer par les
marchands de béton sans que les fonds
publics servent à enrichir ceux ci plus
éventuellement quelques hommes
politiques gratifié d'une bonne
commission pour cette entremise dans des
attributions de marchés
et qu'on ne nous dise pas qu'il n'ya pas
d'argent l'état pourrait dégager des
centaines de milliards de recettes
supplémentaires
rien qu'en revenant en arrière surtout
les avantages accordés au cours des
années précédentes aux entreprises
capitalistes d'une part on riche pris
individuellement
d'autre part il faut augmenter les
ressources de l'état en ramenant au
moins l'impôt
sur les bénéfices des sociétés des 33 %
actuels aux 50% d'il ya dix ans il faut
rétablir les tranches supérieures
d'imposition sur les hauts revenus
pourquoi ce cadeau at il été fait aux
plus favorisés
est-ce que cela permet de créer des
emplois non c'est un cadeau de
politiciens au service des riches et ce
qui est significatif c'est que lionel
jospin ne parle pas de revenir sur cette
injustice au lieu de diminuer les
dépenses de sécurité sociale y compris
celles qui sont indispensables comme le
fait depuis des années
il faut rétablir ses ressources en
ramenant les cotisations patronales au
moins à leur niveau antérieur
il faut supprimer la csg sur les bas
salaires et sur les retraites mais en
revanche l'élargir à tous les autres
revenus surtout ceux du capital avec une
forte progressivité pour les hauts
revenus
il faut supprimer tous les dégrèvements
de charges dont les plus riches
bénéficient scandaleusement il faut
supprimer tous les abattements et
dégrèvements dont bénéficient ceux qui
ont des revenus élevés provenant de
placements de capitaux
ils sont supprimés tous les passe droits
du type de l'avoir fiscal qui permettent
à certains grands patrons de payer
relativement moins d'impôts que leurs
ouvriers les plus mal payés
il faut un véritable impôt sur les
grandes fortunes
c'est pour ce plan d'urgence pour les
chômeurs et les travailleurs que vous
vous prononcerez en votant pour ma
candidature
et si vous êtes des millions à le faire
cela fera un choc suffisant pour que les
travailleurs les chômeurs les jeunes
puissent vérifier qu'ils seront nombreux
à exiger de celui qui sera élu qu'il
tienne même les promesses qu'il n'a pas
fait
[Musique]